e aí
oi boa noite a todos e todas aqui
presentes eu sou a lívia e o ato numa
organização da sociedade civil que há 25
anos luta pela defesa dos direitos de
crianças e adolescentes desde 2006 essa
organização desenvolve um programa que
busca levar à reflexão para a sociedade
sobre o impacto do consumismo na
infância e que defende o fim do
direcionamento de todo e qualquer
publicidade a criança que pela nossa
legislação são as pessoas com menos de
12 anos de idade de modo que propõe o
redirecionamento dessa mensagem
publicitária aos adultos que são os
responsáveis pelas crianças e detentores
do poder de compra
e para começar nossa conversa vale a
gente refletir um pouco sobre a
sociedade que a gente vive vivemos hoje
em uma sociedade de consumo focada na
cultura do consumo sem limites no
consumismo onde o nível de sucesso e
pertencimento é medido pelo consumo de
bens e serviços não importa quais sejam
os seus gostos seus interesses suas
crenças só faixa etária seu poder
aquisitivo todos somos estimulados a
consumir massivamente também é uma
sociedade de espetáculo onde não basta
ter é preciso parecer a busca pela
felicidade está intimamente ligada à
aquisição de bens e serviços e a
exibição desses produtos também é a
sociedade da informação que vive do
poder da informação que produzem se
alimentar de dados o tempo todo
oi para o direcionamento de publicidade
segmentada
bom e o que é esse consumismo consumismo
é diferente de consumo todos nós aqui
consumimos produtos e serviços que
necessitamos diariamente faz parte do
cotidiano o consumismo é um hábito
mental viciado é algo que não é comum a
nossa essência e a nossa natureza é aqui
tem uma frase da ana beatriz barbosa
silva que a médica psiquiatra e ela traz
esse conceito todos nós somos por meio
da publicidade dentro dessa sociedade de
hiperconsumo estimulados a consumir de
modo alienante impulsivamente tem
nenhuma reflexão prévia
é mas a gente parte da premissa de que
ninguém nasce consumista aposto que
vocês leram outra coisa aí mas então
como explicar crianças socadas crianças
preocupadas com o produto da moda com
marcas que têm um novo lançamento ou se
a versão anterior é comum que as
crianças tenham desejos e interesses a
questão é de onde vem esse desejo esse
interesse é um desejo genuíno espontâneo
de por exemplo ter um brinquedo ou de
vestir uma roupa com personagem
estampado do desenho animado ou são
desejos que são incutidos por meio de
mensagens comerciais externas
é a realidade é que dentro dessa
sociedade de hiperconsumo que a gente
vive as crianças não passam imunizar
essa lógica as crianças são bombardeadas
massivamente 360° o tempo todo em
diferentes espaços de convivência e
meios de comunicação que atinjam elas
são estimuladas a desejar produtos e
serviços e apresentá-las dentro do seu
círculo familiar e isso acontece na tv
no shopping no cinema nos pontos de
venda na internet nos aplicativos nas
redes sociais nos parques e praças
públicas e aqui tá dentro das escolas e
aí eu já sei que dentro dessa escola
isso não acontece
é mas o que é publicidade infantil
publicidade é diferente de propaganda
publicidade a comunicação usada para nos
convencer a desejar e consumir produtos
e serviços a propaganda é a comunicação
utilizada para disseminar pensamentos e
ideias sem qualquer apelo comercial a
publicidade infantil é aquela que se
comunica diretamente com a criança que
tem a criança como público-alvo por meio
de elementos e artifícios que são
atrativos a esse público
ah mas por que uma empresa né as
empresas investir em um bilhões em um
mercado infantil porque justamente a
criança sendo que ela não detém o poder
de compra e não detém capacidade
jurídica para celebrar contratos por
exemplo sabe-se que as crianças têm
poder de influência sobre os adultos na
aquisição de bens e serviços dentro do
seu círculo familiar uma pesquisa
brasileira de 2003 aponta que as
crianças brasileiras influenciam e até
oitenta por cento as decisões de compra
de uma família os adultos e tem o poder
de compra mas a influência é sim da
criança não à toa nós vemos uma
infinidade de mensagens e campanhas
publicitárias voltadas diretamente ao
público infantil de produtos do universo
adulto como por exemplo produtos de
limpeza e impermeabilizantes vitamina c
restaurantes hotéis o carro da família e
até operadora de telefonia celular
e aí
e a criança é vista pelo mercado sob
três perspectivas a consumidora hoje a
consumidora do futuro fidelidade adesão
e como promotora de vendas dentro do seu
círculo familiar e de amigos outras
pesquisas apontam inclusive encomendados
por canais infantis da tv fechada que as
crianças utilizam o método de insistir
com seus pais e mães até que eles
vencidos pelo cansaço acabam cedendo
é mas como tá a criança enxerga a
publicidade infantil e quais são os
impactos dessa comunicação mercadológica
bom até os 68 anos a criança sequer
diferencia a publicidade de conteúdo de
programação isso quer dizer se que
dentro de uma novela infantil por
exemplo se você tiver um conteúdo de
merchandising a criança não reconhece
isso como tal até os 12 anos a criança
não identifica o caráter persuasivo da
publicidade ela não sabe que a
publicidade tem por objetivo de
convencer ao desejo e ao consumo do que
está sendo anunciado
e além disso vários estudos e pesquisas
apontam que a publicidade infantil é um
dos elementos que acarreta consequências
sociais negativas como valores e hábitos
materialistas e consumistas distância da
criança com a natureza diminuição de
brincadeiras livres e criativas
adultização e erotização precoce esses
especialmente de meninas prejuízos
ambientais então a cada vez mais
evidente essa relação entre publicidade
infantil consumismo na infância e
insustentabilidade ambiental stress
familiares superendividamento das
famílias violência pela busca de
produtos caros e distúrbios alimentares
e doenças crônicas não transmissíveis
como diabetes especialmente quando a
gente fala de produtos ultraprocessados
não saudáveis que a gente sabe que são
massivamente anunciados ao público
infantil
é também importante dizer que a criança
não só é estimulada por meio dessas
mensagens publicitárias a desejar e
consumir o que está sendo anunciado essa
criança também acaba absorvendo valores
conceitos modelos e padrões a criança a
criança acha que ela precisa ter assim
como amiguinho dela tem essa criança
acaba não sendo responsável pensa que
ela não precisa ser responsável pelas
suas escolhas de consumo que tudo bem
ela colecionar um brinquedo que vem
envolto em camadas e camadas e camadas
de plástico de uso único que vão ser
tratados logo na sequência mas então
como o remar contra a maré como proteger
as nossas crianças do consumismo bom que
a gente tá fazendo aqui já é um começo
além disso a família das escolas também
podem conversar com as crianças sobre
publicidade e consumismo o que é a
publicidade infantil qual é o objetivo
da
o que o consumo leva ao descarte mas
mais do que isso uma maneira bem efetiva
de lutar contra consumismo a respeitando
a lei que existe no brasil desde 1990 a
publicidade infantil é proibido no país
por uma interpretação entre constituição
federal estatuto da criança e
adolescente código de defesa do
consumidor resolução 163 2014 do
conselho nacional dos direitos da
criança do adolescente e o marco legal
da primeira infância a gente pode dizer
que sim a publicidade infantil é abusiva
e ilegal no brasil
é basicamente essas normas dispõe o
seguinte o artigo 227 da constituição
federal prevê o dever compartilhado
entre família estado e sociedade o que
inclui as empresas de garantir com
absoluta prioridade os direitos de
crianças e adolescentes os estatuto da
criança e adolescente que é uma lei de
1990 prevê que a criança é uma pessoa
que está vivendo uma peculiar fase de
desenvolvimento físico cognitivo e
psíquico e social além disso o melhor
interesse da criança e sua proteção
integral devem ser garantidos em
qualquer tipo de relação além disso ele
prever a norma o direito ao respeito ea
inviolabilidade dos seus direitos o
código de defesa do consumidor que é a
lei de 1990 que regula as relações de
consumo prevê que a publicidade deve ser
fácil e imediatamente identificável pelo
seu público-alvo que como a gente já viu
não acontece com as crianças
é abusiva a publicidade que se aproveita
da falta de experiência e julgamento da
criança o marco legal da primeira
infância que é uma lei mais recente de
2016 prever um ponto prioritário a
proteção contra a pressão consumista e
adoção de medidas que evitem a exposição
precoce da criança a comunicação
mercadológica
é em resumo o que eu quero dizer aqui
partindo dessa premissa de que ninguém
nasce consumista é que o hiperconsumo
ele é responsável por prejuízos sociais
e ambientais que publicidade infantil é
antiética é injusta e ilegal pela
legislação existente no brasil o
redirecionamento da publicidade para os
adultos que são os verdadeiros
responsáveis pelas crianças e detentores
do poder de compra não culpabilização
das famílias e das escolas
responsabilização das primeiras
responsabilização das empresas é surreal
a gente pensar que cabe apenas as
famílias e as escolas evitar que as
crianças sejam submetidas e expostas
apelos comerciais é preciso primeiro que
as empresas se limitem a
responsabilidade que lhe cabe de cumprir
a lei e não direcionar suas mensagens
publicitárias a esse público assim a
gente vai ter uma infância livre de
consumismo
oi e aí por fim eu deixo algumas
perguntas de reflexão sobre a infância
estamos proporção das nossas crianças e
que geração de adultos nós estamos
formando nós estamos formando cidadãos
responsáveis conscientes e livres pelas
suas escolhas de consumo ou pessoas
consumistas eternamente desejantes
insatisfeitas que vivem em busca do novo
lançamento é isso muito obrigada